PAUL BAKAUS: Welcome, everyone.
Welcome, everyone,
to our session
about the latest and
hottest in DevTools in 2014.
Now my name is Paul Bakaus, and
I work with the DevTools team
to enable you to create,
develop and design
and obviously debug your
sites and applications.
So for those of
you that don't know
and haven't worked with
DevTools before, now here's
a quick primer.
The Chrome DevTools are
dedicated to delivering
you a real time
debugging, profiling,
and development environment.
So here's just a quick few
images of what it enables.
But we'll dig into some of that.
So we think they're
your DevTools.
That's very important to stress.
We'd like you think of DevTools
as a friendly assistant
in your daily life, guiding you
and hiding unneeded complexity,
and helping you focus on
work that matters most.
So in 2014, more so
than ever, the time
has come to build fully
responsive websites and apps
to serve the whole screen
continuum of devices, rather
than just the single device
category, because right now,
many sites just have a
mobile version of the site
and then a desktop
version of the site.
And the desktop version
can be used on the iPads.
But the iPad
obviously uses touch.
And it's not the
same environment.
And then, obviously, right in
the middle, there's tablets.
And really, the lines
are getting blurry.
With my watch here, there's
another completely different
screen.
And so it's very important
to build out the whole screen
continuum.
And if you're not convinced,
just look at the data.
Right?
If we're looking at
the mobile web traffic,
not just smartphones in general,
but the mobile web traffic
clearly shows that we need
to do something about this.
We need to build mobile
websites and mobile
in a very broad sense.
But are we up for the challenge?
Is our workflow good enough?
And I think it's not.
I think, clearly, there's
really some challenges
that we're looking at.
We moved so quickly
to that wave,
to mobile, that we forgot
to build the right tools.
And I mean that in the best
sense of the word, "flow."
Workflow has the
word, "flow" in it.
And flow is really
the state of mind
where you're very immersed.
So really, the ideal case is
this meditating Buddhist monk.
And you're in this
immersed state of mind.
You're very energized.
It's like when you
have a coding session,
and you develop
for a couple hours,
and you listen to great music,
and you're very in there.
And you're very fully involved,
and it's a great feeling,
right?
You're enjoying yourself.
You're getting stuff done.
It's great.
But I think if you're
working with lots of devices,
you'd probably rather
look like this guy,
because what do you do when you
develop with actual devices?
Well, first of all, you
have to buy actual devices.
You have to get them.
You have to put
them in the closet.
You have to charge them.
You have to, obviously,
connect them when you need them
and play with the
finicky eye to reload.
And it's all just not very nice.
It breaks you out of your
development workflow.
And you have to
come back and forth,
because you're debugging
on your desktop.
And then finally you
realize, OK, I probably
need to check on my phone.
And obviously, that's
not the ideal workflow.
So we went back to
the drawing board
and really thought hard
about this problem.
How can we come up with a
disruptive flow that works?
That just works and gets the
job done and doesn't really
disrupt the flow, a
non-disruptive flow,
we'll have to say,
so a flow that
doesn't disrupt
you from your work?
Right?
Something that feels natural.
And we found there
are really three areas
for radical improvement,
design, develop, and iterate.
And in that order,
actually, because when
you start developing, you
probably get a designer PSD.
So you take the PSD, and
you transform it into code,
into HTML and CSS.
And then you probably expand it.
Because the designer only
gave you one resolution,
you expand it to multiple media
queries and work off there.
And then next is development.
And actually, I think
that's design as well.
I think you're doing a design
work if you're an engineer.
Then you move over to develop.
And so you're
developing, you're trying
to develop under conditions that
feel relatively similar to what
you want to achieve.
So you resize your
browser window.
You're trying to
make sense of, OK,
if this is a Nexus 5 resolution,
this is a iPhone resolution.
And then, finally,
once you're ready,
you want to iterate
on actual devices,
because they have unique works
and nasty bugs sometimes.
So really, you need
to get in there
and test some actual devices.
So let's focus on each of these
and write it into design first.
So I mentioned it
before, but we have
the screen continuum of devices.
And what's really
important, we're
looking at responsive
layouts here.
We want a layout that stretches
to a multitude of resolutions.
And that's because mobile
is the number one platform.
So you want to make
sure your content just
flows like water, flows into
different containers easily.
There's lots of
tools that actually
try to see something
similar nowadays,
but many start from the desktop,
so designed for the desktop.
And then you break down
and write media queries
for smaller resolutions.
But you really want to make sure
to start with the mobile site,
because otherwise, you
forget about the mobile site.
And if you don't have
a mobile website,
you just don't have
a website in 2014.
It's easy as that.
If you don't have a mobile
website, you have no website.
Well, let me explain you the
old web flow for a bit, right?
In the design process,
I take my website--
so that's my website--
I build it mobile first.
So what are we doing next?
Well, I go back to
my editor, and I'm
going to add some
media queries in there.
Right?
I'm going to put media
queries in there,
and I'm going to build a tablet
media query for instance.
Now, I go back to my website,
reload under the roughly tablet
conditions, and find out that
it's still not the right size.
So I get back to my editor,
I change some values again,
go back to the
preview, reload again,
shift pixels around,
until my elements appear
where they should be appearing.
And it's painful.
I'm going back and forth
and back and forth,
and I don't like that.
I mean, I'm not sure
about you, but I'm
really am not a fan
of that workflow.
So we thought we could do
better than that, much better,
actually.
But let's go one step next to
emulation and the development
aspect of it.
So now, you have all
media queries in there.
And you have a
responsive layout.
You still realize that
browser window resizing is not
the same as emulating
a smartphone, Right?
So show me some hands.
Who actually tests
on real devices?
All right, quite a few.
Who tests on more
than 10 devices?
Oh, I see much less hands.
There's some of you,
and you're great.
You're amazing.
But really, you know
how painful it is.
I mean, not everyone
has the ability
to acquire all these devices
to get a device lab set up,
in order to get all
kinds of data plans.
And so we went out
a couple months ago
and we put in emulation
controls into DevTools.
So some of you might
already have seen that.
It wasn't ready at
last I/O, but emulation
controls that
emulate the viewport,
emulate touch events,
and various other things,
the user agent.
But that was just a start.
It was [INAUDIBLE].
And I think we could do
much better than that.
So how can we get from this
guy, the very frustrated guy,
to the Buddhist monk
that's meditating?
Well, I'm incredibly
[INAUDIBLE] today
to announce, to introduce,
our new device mode.
Here we go.
So the device mode is
a one-click action--
I'm going to show
it you obviously--
that combines the
best of media queries
with emulation and much more.
So are you ready for a demo?
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Let me show you some
of the Device Mode.
There we go.
Just move that over here.
And we want to make it bigger.
Actually, just give
me a tiny second.
I hope that works.
I'm going to try to change
the resolution quickly
to make more sense out of this.
Yes.
All right.
There we go.
So I'll just click the button.
Here we go.
So this is one of
our sites that we
built where you can learn all
about mobile development, web
fundamentals.
And web fundamentals
is a nice example
for a responsive website,
which is why I picked it.
So I'm going to bring
up DevTools here.
And here we go.
And now, in DevTools,
you'll notice--
I'm just going to zoom
in, so you can see this--
you'll notice a new icon
next to the Inspect icon,
and it's a mobile phone.
So if click that icon, it brings
up our new responsive design
mode, or device mode,
as we now call it.
Now let me focus
on a few things.
First of all, it makes it very
easy to change your layout.
So you can quickly change your
layout to whatever you want to.
And as you can see, now
it emulates touch events
right out of the box.
So it's a one-click action
into mobile web development.
Really, we wanted to make
it as simple as possible
to get you there.
So to emulate the
viewport characteristics
of a mobile phone, but it
also emulates touch events out
of the box.
Now you can go further than
that because, as you can see up
here, you have all sorts
of device emulation
right in there.
So we have a couple
of device presets
that you can choose
from to quickly emulate
a certain device.
So let's try to pick out
one, let's say Nexus 5.
All right.
So this is the
Nexus 5 resolution.
It's set the right
resolution here.
I can mess with
that if I want to.
I can also rotate it, of course,
to find out different ones.
So I get a warning here
that I have to reload,
because sometimes
there's service side
processing involved
into figuring out
the right viewport.
Let me re-log this to
actually make it look nice.
Here we go.
So this looks like
a mobile website.
And now, again, I can rotate it.
And also, very importantly,
I could test retina here.
So some of these devices
have high DPI screens.
And I can easily change the
device pixel ratio right here--
yes, I think I'm pointing
to it-- to actually test
my images with the new
picture element or image set.
So let's see.
We also have a
[INAUDIBLE] in there.
So if you're developing
on smaller screens,
so I just change the
resolution to make
it a bit smaller in this one.
If you're developing
on smaller screens
and you pick
something that is big,
it shrinks the whole thing.
So let me reload this again
to bring the rulers back.
So now it's all shrinked.
But you can disable
that if you want to.
Oop.
Here we go.
So you can easily just preview.
And this is just
scale, so you can still
work with it just naturally.
So let's see.
Let's go back to
Nexus 5 and show you
what the design aspect of
this is in there, of course.
Because what we have in
here is this nice button,
and it brings up media queries.
Here you go.
So this is a view of all of
your media queries on the site
right there.
So as you can see,
I'm resizing this,
so you can get a better view.
Those are all
running on the site.
And if I click on one of them,
it jumps to the right size.
So I can easily
preview all of them
and edit them in
the style drawer.
And one very important
thing as well.
If I right-click
on one of them--
let's say this green
one over here--
and it gives me a
drop-down and tells me
exactly where that
media query is.
So I could jump right into the
source here, this one right
there.
Now this is obfuscated, so I
could freely print this one.
And it would then go
directly to that media query.
Let's try this again.
Here we go.
Oh.
There we are.
All right.
And then edit it right
in there, because we
have a new feature in
DevTools called Workspaces
that, if you
haven't used it yet,
connects your local file
system of your website
with the file
system in DevTools.
And so I hit Control S,
for instance, to size
it directly back to
your file system.
So finally, one feature that
is really nifty in combination
with media queries.
Because if you're nesting
many media queries,
that would become very useful.
Let's say I'm just
going up here,
and I want to change
this caption right there.
So I inspect it-- well, I'm
trying to find the button.
No, that's was the wrong one.
OK, let's try it this way.
Actually, it's pretty hard to
see the screen from over here.
OK, let's actually
just do it like this.
Right?
So I have an element here.
And then what I can do
here is style filtering.
So a nice nifty feature
that we brought in
that you might have
discovered yet already,
but it's very nifty
because, if you
have lots of styles
on top of an element
and you want to find something
out about the element,
you can quickly click in here.
Let's see what do we have here?
Line height for instance, right?
And just type a
couple of letters,
and it highlights
them, brings up
exactly what you
just searched for.
And you can edit them.
So that becomes very
useful with media queries.
So finally, if you don't
want to have this view open
all the time, because you just
want to focus on your content,
well, if you close this
again, you'll notice--
and I hope you can see it-- but
there are some rulers in here.
On the ruler, there are some
sticks that you can click.
So those here are actually
the media queries right there.
And if you click
on them, it just
brings up that view all again.
So this is a nice preview
of what you're looking at.
And finally, now some of
you that have used emulation
before, there's more, obviously.
So there's still a lot
more that you can emulate.
We just put the best,
what you probably
need right way up here.
But if you click on
that button right here,
it opens up the original
emulation controls
in Detail mode.
And that allows you
to emulate all kinds
of sensory information,
accelerometer, geolocation,
user agent, you name it.
So finally, of course, you might
not just work on mobile, right?
Maybe you also want to
develop your website
so it looks fine on desktop.
Well, you can do that as well.
This jumps you right
into mobile view.
But if you want to
do media queries
and design a desktop page,
you just hit the reset button.
And the reset button,
as you can see,
removes the viewport rulers,
removes the touch event
emulation, so we're back
to normal mouse event,
and its hover
effects work again,
and you basically just keep
on resizing your window
like you did before,
but with media queries.
So now, let's go back to the
presentation for a moment,
because we're not done yet.
We think that we don't have
a complete story to tell yet.
So let's talk a bit
about connectivity.
Now in your office Wi-Fi,
if you have lots of devices
and they're all connected
to your office Wi-Fi,
you probably have a very good
experience loading your page.
Now let's say, for the
sake of an argument,
just for the sake
of an argument,
you're at the conference.
Right?
And it's the same
connection type, right?
You're basically on
a Wi-Fi connection.
But I argue it's probably
not the same experience
to your office.
Now this is an important
aspect of testing,
because how do you know what
your users actually experience
if you don't have a 3G
connection to test on?
And it's like, you
know, I'm a German guy.
German Autobahn, versus
American Autobahn.
And we really think the
whole story is not complete,
the whole emulation
story is simply not
complete without connectivity,
without network emulation.
So I'm incredibly
excited to show you--
and you might have seen it
already on the demo-- I mean,
crazy excited to show you.
And I think we're the first
to do this, to show you
network emulation
right in your browser.
So let's jump back to the demo.
Here we go.
And let's use a different page.
I'm going to pick the
Huffington Post right here.
It's the US device.
OK.
So OK, I'm going to bring
up the DevTools again.
I have a new network panel here.
Right?
So I'm looking at the
network data coming in.
So let me reload the page,
just so you get a picture.
OK, so stuff is loading here.
And OK, it's obviously not that
fast, but we're getting there.
And it's currently
set to no throttling.
OK, page is loaded.
And now, do I actually--
now, I don't want Flash.
No!
OK.
So now let's actually
bring this to a-- oh,
this is why it took so long.
So it brings us to
another resolution,
and then reload again.
Here we go.
So now we have a mobile website.
It's loading, but it's loading
too fast, because, OK, I'm
on a [? Grand AM ?]
on a conference Wi-Fi.
It's not as good
as office Wi-Fi,
but let's just try to simulate
the [INAUDIBLE] connection,
so let's go to--
what do we have here?
Let's say Edge, right?
Unfortunately, in
Germany, we still
have Edge in some
remote destinations.
And let's try to reload
this and see what happens.
So here we go.
Blank page.
And pretend I didn't
know how the soccer
game went this morning.
Right?
And I want to check it out.
I'm like, no, what is happening?
Can't this train go
out of the tunnel?
And that might happen, as well.
[APPLAUSE]
Yes.
Right?
Even worse.
That's even worse.
Now I can never find
out how that game went.
Ah.
OK, let's bring this up again.
Just bear with me for a second.
Here we go.
Yes.
All right.
And yeah.
So this is network throttling.
You saw the connection
is actually quite slower.
And this feature is
still experimental,
as with the others.
It's Canary right now.
So you can check it out,
you can download it,
and you can play with it.
But this is the first time
I've been seeing that crash,
I swear.
It's usually relatively stable.
Now one important thing.
And this is something
that was hard to do,
but is obvious once you use it.
This network
emulation-- you might
have played with
some others, right?
You might have played with
tools that dragged down
your entire connection, like
Link Conditioner or Apple
internal software.
But those do it for
your whole system.
Now this one does it per tab.
So even if you completely
hog down one tab,
you can still query for
documentation in another tab.
And not only does it
throttle, but it also
goes completely offline.
So if I hit this one and go
to the offline one right here,
it does what I would expect.
I reload the page, and it
tells me, hey, I'm offline.
I didn't have to
unplug my connection.
[INAUDIBLE] my Wi-Fi.
And I could still now Google for
documentation about App Cache,
because we all know
App Cache is horrible.
So very useful feature.
Yes, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So let's go back to
the slides once more.
Iteration.
So now that I've showed
you all this emulation
stuff in the new Device
mode, let's switch
to actual devices for a second.
And you might be thinking, what?
He just talked
about all this stuff
and how I can
improve my workflow.
And now he still wants to get
me the devices and plug them in?
That's weird.
But I think, that
was the world before.
Right?
So this is the PainStation.
And the PainStation
is a version of Pong.
It's very fun to play, actually.
It electrifies and
burns you when you fail.
But that makes it kind
of adrenaline-pumping.
It's adventurous.
And that was the world
of device testing before.
But luckily, it's easier now.
And it has to be, because
testing with actual emulation
is not the same as a smartphone.
No matter how hard we try, we
can't simulate the whole thing.
We can't just, because there's
different graphics drivers,
there's different
characteristics
on every single device.
There are devices out there,
like the Samsung Galaxy
S3, which is a great phone, but
it has three different hardware
versions across
the globe, I think.
And it's very hard to
test for all of them.
So you have to have
devices to actually test.
Now what are the reasons for
you to actually use devices?
Well, performance profiling,
device-specific glitches,
as I just mentioned,
and the context.
What do I mean by context?
Well, the look and feel, right?
If you're looking at
something on your desktop,
and everything is very big, and
you don't actually touch there,
but you use your
mouse to navigate,
you will press the buttons every
time, even if they're tiny.
But if you have a
device in your hand
that's actually much tinier,
you'll have a harder time.
So the context is
extremely important.
So let's first talk about
performance profiling.
And actually, no.
Let's dig into
performance profiling,
because performance
profiling, in my opinion,
is one of the most
important aspects of it.
And I want to show you
a demo for this as well.
And as I said, before,
it was very painful,
but we tried to make
it very, very simple.
Maybe not like this
keyboard right here,
because that becomes
a bit useless.
But we try to make it
equally simple with remaining
functionality.
So let's show you what we did.
All right.
I'm going to get my
Chromium up here again.
Here we go.
I'm going to switch
to another site.
Here we go.
And now I'm going
to open DevTools
to show you exactly
what happens.
So I'm bringing up my Nexus 5K.
That's just an
unmodified Nexus 5.
I have my USB
connection right here.
I'm going to plug this in.
Here we go.
What just happened?
Well, let me show you.
Right in that corner we get
another small mobile icon,
and it shows me that
one device is connected.
That's all I did.
I just plugged my phone in.
There's nothing I
did on my phone yet.
Well, I'm clicking on this, and
it brings up a new device panel
right down here.
Oop.
Here we go.
So this tells me that I
just connected my Nexus 5,
and it's running Chromium.
So what can I do now?
Well, I'm going unlock
my screen just now.
Here we go.
So I see this works.
So I have Chrome
open on my screen.
You'll just have to believe me.
I'm going to click Try Here.
Now what this does now-- let
me move this screen over-- this
just opened this new screen.
And network connection
is a bit slow right now,
but let's just wait for it.
So while we're waiting,
what just happened?
Well, I told
DevTools that I want
to try the page I just
opened on my phone,
and I want to test
it on my phone.
So what it did when clicking Try
Here, it sent it to my phone,
it loaded it in
a new tab, and it
opened a new remote
debugging session right away.
But not only that, it also
opened screencasts right away.
So what this is
doing, it's actually
screencasting from my device
right on to my desktop.
And if that wasn't cool enough,
now this is all interactive.
So it's all emulation
right in there.
Not actually emulation,
but this is my real phone.
I'm navigating on my
real phone right now.
I can click stuff here.
I can even inspect
stuff here, right?
So this is all live.
And the best of it is that
all of DevTools is in there.
It's not just the light
version of DevTools,
it's the full
version of DevTools.
So let me show you
some of the features
that you could use to
debug performance in there.
And I'm going to highlight
some of the new stuff.
So first of all, this is a
nifty 3D effect, hopefully.
Let's try again.
I think it's not
a nifty 3D effect,
because it's still loading.
OK, let's try this again.
So the effect we're actually
looking at is this one.
So this is the 3D effect.
And let's try it again.
There we go.
The page is just very slow
right now, but you know what?
I'm going to show you the
feature outside of that tab.
But you just have to
pretend that this one is
the mobile phone you
were just looking at.
But again, the features
are all compatible.
So now, as you can see, I have
a new Layers panel right here.
So the Layers panel will give
me a presentation, a preview,
of what's happening on
my page, all the layers
that I used to render
certain things in there.
So now I can rotate this and
look at what's happening.
So I can see that
many layers here
stacked on top of each other.
And if I click the toggle,
check out what happens.
Here we go.
So all of this
rendered in real time.
And I can click on them
and do stuff with it.
But even better, one of the
new features in here-- and just
to let you know, all of
this is experimental,
and the UI will likely change--
but we built in a paint
profiler right here, because
one of the common problems
with mobile phones is painting.
And painting happens often
on the GPU, but not always.
So let me double-click this guy.
And now what it did here,
it rendered the whole page,
the whole document, onto
that background surface
of the graphical representation
that I have here.
And now down here-- just
resizing that window
so you can see what I'm looking
at, here we go-- down here,
you actually get a profile.
So now we can see what
painting that whole thing did.
There we go.
So let me zoom in again, just
to show you what happened.
So now I'm going to select
a certain thing here.
And then, as you can see, as I'm
dragging around and selecting
new parts, it renders
what is just drawn.
So I see all the drawing
commands that just happened.
And I can quickly
follow and find out
what took so long to paint.
I have spikes right at
the beginning and here.
And those, I think, are
some of the border radiuses
that we're seeing in
the Toggle button.
So this is a very
nice, convenient way
to figure out what
took so long to paint.
But let me show you
another feature.
So let's talk about profiling.
So when you want to know how
things animate on the timeline,
you go over into
Timeline, here we go,
and you look at what's
happening in here.
I'm going to reload this.
There we go.
Now we've got some
stuff recorded.
And yes, I don't see anything.
My cursor is just too big.
Here we go.
I think now we're seeing stuff.
It's hard to say.
Just give me a second.
OK.
Why don't you try that again?
OK there we go.
So now we actually have
some stuff down here.
So we're seeing some of the
events that just happened.
There's, for whatever reason,
just network events right now.
But the timeline
is useful if you
want to see what's happening
while you're loading your page.
So now we're seeing
what happened
in the network requests.
But the problem is
sometimes I want
to know what took
so long to paint.
But I also want to know
why did it paint so long?
And it's often JavaScript
that caused it to paint.
So earlier, we didn't
have the ability
to combine those two
to actually find out,
hey, this job's just
run, and a relayout
happened because
a JavaScript run.
And before, you basically
had to go through the profile
and then record a CPO
profile on JavaScripts.
So you would run this.
And then you would stop it.
And then you would
look at, OK, now
what happens here on
the page, obviously.
But you would look at what
actually just happened.
But now-- this is another
experimental feature,
but I think it's a very
good one-- now what
we did here is to combine
JavaScript profiling
with the Timeline.
So if I click this Flame
Chart icon right here,
it switches to a different view.
I'm going to record
this and reload.
Let's hope this works.
No?
All right.
That doesn't make a
great demo right now.
Weird.
OK.
So what's supposed to happen,
in that thing down here, you
will be able to
see your Timeline
commands in a nice
Flame Chart, as well as
what's happening in JavaScript.
So for instance, if you're
loading Google Analytics,
and this page is loading
Google Analytics,
you see that it loaded
Google Analytics.
But down there,
you also see what
just happened after it loaded
it, so what it initialized
and what is
happening after that.
And so in the case
of Google Analytics,
it adds some stats to the
page that cause a relayout.
And you will notice that, when
you have a working view that
actually shows you that.
So a couple of
performance features
that didn't work out
that well in the demo.
But again, toy
with them at home.
And I hope they'll work
better on your computer.
So let's move back.
So again, all of these
features, everything
that's in DevTools, even the
most advanced performance
stuff, is available
to you everywhere,
including the ones
I just showed you.
And they work with
every device run
in Chrome, even the Chromecast.
So we have design, develop,
and iterate right here.
We think today's
DevTools refresh
is going to make you a
lot happier, hopefully,
and more productive.
And we'd love to hear
from you if it does,
and especially if it doesn't.
So design went to
responsive layouts, develop
went to rich
emulation, and iterate
to a interremote debugging.
So in responsive
layouts, I showed you
a rich representation of media
queries, style filtering, media
query editing.
And it plays well
with inline emulation
all together in that big few.
Now in emulation, you
have device presets
for most popular devices, rich
viewport emulation, sensor
emulation, and
the advanced panel
down there with touch
geolocation accelerometer,
and-- and this is a very
cool new feature-- network
throttling and offline
support per tab.
And finally, with
remote debugging,
once you have a pretty
good website set up,
you just plug and play.
It's as easy as that.
You take your phone,
you plug it in.
It brings up a new panel that
shows you one connected device.
And it has the same
powerful features.
It screencasts from your device
directly onto your laptop.
And it also supports
port forwarding
for those advanced
use cases where
you want to develop
a local host,
and not just on a remote
website, you can do that.
There's an Advanced
panel down there
that supports port forwarding.
So you just put in, hey, I
want to forward local host
to this port on my device.
And as soon as
you have that, you
can debug local hosts
right on your device.
So before we completely
finish, we've almost
arrived at the
end, but I want you
to know that you're all
invited to collaborate with us.
Because if you look at that
screen, all of the things
that you're seeing here, they
all have something in common.
They're coming from you.
They're coming
from the community.
All of these features are
because you just told us
what you want.
So we really value
your feature requests,
no matter how big or small.
See, if we don't
hear from you, we'll
build the DevTools
that we like, right?
But we'd much rather build
the DevTools you like.
So do get in touch.
Every bug ticket counts.
So suddenly, this marks
the end of the session.
Come speak with me and many
others involved in DevTools
at the Sandbox afterwards.
And we'll have a QA
afterwards as well, so enjoy
the rest of your I/O. Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Excuse me?
PAUL BAKAUS: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: One more question.
Does the connection
throttling feature
work for such technologies as
Web Artistry or [? WebSTAC ?]?
PAUL BAKAUS: Yes, it does.
AUDIENCE: Even for [INAUDIBLE]
connection numbers?
PAUL BAKAUS: I'm
pretty sure it does.
I will have to check
on UDP connections.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
PAUL BAKAUS: Yeah.
I'm going to look into
that, but I'm pretty sure.
AUDIENCE: Do these work with
WebView, all these features?
PAUL BAKAUS: With WebView?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
With the--
PAUL BAKAUS: The
remote debugging?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PAUL BAKAUS: Yep.
AUDIENCE: OK, great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi, is this working?
PAUL BAKAUS: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So just a quick question.
I saw that you had a
list of drop-down devices
for mobile, like
that you can-- how
do you get a device in there?
Will it work for
other form factors,
like if there's Chrome on--
PAUL BAKAUS: Very good question.
We're trying to customize this.
We're trying to make
it customizable.
And we're thinking about a
couple of interesting ideas
here.
Like for instance,
you could potentially
plug in your phone
and remote debug it.
And it would then ask you to add
the profile to your emulation.
So we get that.
It's a common use case that
not all of these devices
are the ones you
want to test on.
And we're working on that.
AUDIENCE: For the
emulation for the device,
if you can have
the Chrome browser
and the internet browser
that it comes with,
which one is it
that gets emulated?
PAUL BAKAUS: Sorry?
So you get the Chrome--
AUDIENCE: So on the Samsung,
on the Samsung notes and tabs,
there's an internet
browser that it comes with.
And then you can install Chrome.
So which one is the
one that gets emulated?
PAUL BAKAUS: You mean
that gets emulated?
Or when you remote inspect it?
AUDIENCE: When it gets
emulated in the tool.
PAUL BAKAUS: So probably Chrome.
But there will be
quirks in there
that we can't probably emulate.
So even the Samsung browsers
nowadays is based on Chromium.
And for instance, we don't
emulate the whole UI, right?
So there's limited things
that we can do there.
So my guess is that
even if we would
have two different
profiles, they
will look roughly the
same, because they
have the same resolution.
But yeah, I hope that
answers your question.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that the network emulator
worked on individual tabs.
Is it the same for
the emulator as well?
PAUL BAKAUS: Yes, for
the emulator as well.
Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: Does the
device emulator
primarily emulate
the resolution?
Or does it actually emulate
the JavaScript engine
and the HTML renderer
for the device?
PAUL BAKAUS: Primarily the
sensors and the resolution,
so with JavaScript.
So yes, and that will
be a cool feature.
I mean, where we have
considered thinking
about removing certain features
that don't work on the device.
But we don't have that
in there right now.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does the
device emulator
bring in Android fonts?
Or does it emulate
typography as well?
PAUL BAKAUS: Very good question.
No, right now it doesn't.
But that would be very
interesting, actually.
Yeah.
That's a good point.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
PAUL BAKAUS: Yes?
AUDIENCE: The device emulator
and network throttling
are fantastic features.
Is there any way to use
them with automated testing
tools like Selenium?
PAUL BAKAUS: Well, for that,
I guess you would need an API.
And there's no API yet.
But we're very early in the
life cycle of that feature,
so it's very
possible, especially
if you open a bug ticket and
tell me that you want it.
So please do.
And I can't promise, but I
think the use case is clear.
And yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is there any plan of
adding Android browsers
as well that can remote
debug Android browsers along
with Chromium?
PAUL BAKAUS: Well, we can only
do that if the Android browsers
are actually based on Chromium.
If they are, we probably
should be able to,
but it's hard to say.
I mean, with
Chrome, we obviously
control the environment
on both ends.
And with the Android stock
browser, we often don't.
But we try our best to
bring it everywhere we can.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey, is the
remote debugging only
possible in KitKat
and up Android?
Or it's also possible in iOS?
PAUL BAKAUS: It's right now
only possible on Android.
I'm not sure if we can
change that for iOS.
It's just a technical
limitation right now,
because we can't put
Chromium onto iOS.
We have to use their WebView.
So for instance, if
they would implement
the same remote
debugging protocol,
we could probably connect them.
But we don't have that
today, unfortunately.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can the bandwidth menu with
offline and then online can
be used to test up where you
have saved something locally
and then sync back
once you're online?
You know, changes the state of--
PAUL BAKAUS: Yes.
Absolutely.
That's what it's for,
so you can completely
emulate application scenarios
and the upcoming service worker
scenarios.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
First off, thank you,
for all these features.
They look really useful.
PAUL BAKAUS: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
And my question is, this new
black design of the emulation
panel looks much different
than the rest of the DevTools.
Is it the beginning
of something bigger?
Are you introducing black theme
through the whole DevTools
or something like that?
PAUL BAKAUS: Very good question.
So the reason why we designed
that feature different
than the rest of
the DevTools was
because it's inline
in the page, so it's
wrapped around the page.
Right?
And we wanted it
to not be in focus,
once you concentrate
on the page.
We want it to be sort of
in the background, which
is why we choose for that
color theme and look.
Now I think we
like that new look.
And maybe it'll come to
more of the DevTools.
But you'll have to tell
us what you like best.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Casting from the device
to the desktop always
has a problem with lag,
because it's slower.
Is there a way to read the real
frames per second of the device
and get that sent
through to the DevTools?
PAUL BAKAUS: I
think we're trying
to do that as much as possible.
But you're right.
I mean, there is a lag
problem, depending, of course,
on the resolution and other
characteristics of the phone.
If we can speed it
up, we'll do it.
I mean, we'll try
as much as possible.
I can't actually
say more than that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'll file a bug.
PAUL BAKAUS: OK.
Cool.
Yes.
All right.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]